I would like to encourage us as a community of 7 million C++ developers around the world, as we consider C++'s future, to push the boundaries to bring C++ itself forward and double down on C++, not be quick to switch to something else. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 98 recorded on September 25, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce, we continue our conversation with Sean Baxter about the future of C++ and all of the C++ successor projects. What do you think of that? And like, also, like if you had a crystal ball or you had to bet, you know, five, 10 years from now, what do you, what do you think the low-level language space is going to, is everyone going to be writing in circle? Is it going to be
作为全球 700 万 C++ 开发者社区的一员，我希望当我们考虑 C++ 的未来时，能够打破常规，推动 C++ 自身向前发展，并全力押注 C++，而不是急于转向其他语言。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 98 期，录制于 2022 年 9 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联席主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们继续与肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）探讨 C++ 的未来以及所有 C++ 继承者项目。你对此怎么看？而且，如果你有一个水晶球或者必须打个赌，你知道，从现在起五、十年后，你认为低级语言领域会发展成怎样，每个人都会用 Circle 编程吗？它会是
C++ is just going to be in slow decline or i mean i my whole adult life has been c++ and i don't want to learn a new language just because other people say i should learn it or because other people say it's better i am i feel confident in c++ it can express my intent and we can make it better. And also, there's another million people who have been using this language successfully with some frustration, sure, but they've built the whole modern world out of C++. And I think we're going to keep with this language. We should make it better. And we should kind of honor this, you know, multi-billion dollar software investment that's been built up over decades. And I think the future will
C++ 只会走向缓慢的衰退，或者说——我的整个成年生活都伴随着 C++，我不想仅仅因为别人说我应该学、或者别人说它更好就去学一门新语言。我对 C++ 充满信心，它能表达我的意图，而且我们可以让它变得更好。此外，还有另外上百万人在成功地使用这门语言，虽然肯定也伴随着一些挫折，但他们用 C++ 构建了整个现代世界。我认为我们会继续使用这门语言。我们应该让它变得更好。我们应该某种程度上尊重这项历经数十年构建起来的、价值数十亿美元的软件投资。我认为未来会
look, hopefully, like today looks, just with a better language. I mean, I just don't see everyone jumping to Rust and then putting these huge, complicated source bases in jeopardy. They say Rust is safer, but not when you have to rewrite everything you already have. I agree with Sean, and I think our biggest problem is our evolution process. And I think that if we can improve our evolution process and if we can, if we can develop the willpower to make C++ a better language, I'm, I'm confident that we can do so. I do not believe that there are fundamental technical challenges that,
看起来，希望就像今天一样，只是语言更优秀了。我的意思是，我实在看不出所有人都会蜂拥转向 Rust，然后将这些庞大而复杂的代码库置于危险境地。他们说 Rust 更安全，但当你必须重写你已有的所有东西时，它就不安全了。我同意肖恩的看法，我认为我们最大的问题是我们的演进流程。而且我认为，如果我们能改进演进流程，如果我们能、如果我们能培养出让 C++ 成为一门更好语言的意志力，我、我有信心我们能做到这一点。我不认为存在根本性的技术挑战，
that cannot be overcome here. I think we could move two, three, four or five times faster. If, if we had a better evolution model and, you know, not everybody's going to necessarily be happy about, um, what moving faster would look like. Um, and it would mean, I think everybody would have to make some compromises. But I think that it's doable.
在这里是无法克服的。我认为我们可以把速度提升两倍、三倍、四倍甚至五倍，如果、如果我们有一个更好的演进模型，而且，你知道，并不是每个人都会对加快速度的外在表现感到满意；而且这意味着，我认为每个人都必须做出一些妥协。但我认为这是可行的。
I do think that if anything dooms the language, it would be that. But I don't think C++ is going anywhere. I just don't want to see it go the route of a COBOL or a FORTRAN because it's not kept up with the times. Yeah. I think any language you can imagine, I think we can really get there from C++. And I think maybe that's the shortest line even because it's so hard to generate new user base. Apple could do it with Swift because you had to buy into their whole Objective-C slash Swift framework.
我确实认为，如果有什么会毁掉这门语言，那就是这个原因。但我认为 C++ 不会消亡。我只是不想看到它因为没有与时俱进而重蹈 COBOL 或 FORTRAN 的覆辙。是的。我认为你能想象到的任何语言，我们真的都可以通过 C++ 实现。而且我认为这甚至可能是最短的路径，因为建立新的用户群太难了。苹果可以通过 Swift 做到这一点，因为你必须接受他们整个 Objective-C 转 Swift 的框架。
They have a kind of a walled garden. But for everyone else, if you start with C++ user base, man, what an amazing amount of momentum you have going forward. And it's not just the user base. It's the ecosystem too. It's like inertia is king in software. Like if you have
他们有一个类似围墙花园的东西。但对其他人来说，如果你从 C++ 的用户群开始，天哪，你向前推进的势头是多么惊人。而且不仅仅是用户群。还有生态系统。这就好比在软件领域，惯性就是王道。如果你有
something that has inertia... I think momentum, you should say momentum. I mean, inertia's kind of got negative connotations, but... Okay, alright. Momentum is key in software. And everything that I've seen in my career
具有惯性的东西…… 我觉得你应该说是势头。我的意思是，惯性有点负面含义，但…… 好吧，好吧。势头是软件领域的关键。我在职业生涯中看到的一切
tells me that everything i've seen in my career tells me that it's better to try and incrementally improve what you have in front of you instead of rewriting it all from scratch i i get that the rewriting it all from scratch has worked for Arthur Whitney. And I certainly, I get that there's times when that is the right thing to do, but the cost for that is so high, especially when you've got an ecosystem and a developer base out there,
告诉我，我在职业生涯中看到的一切告诉我，最好是尝试对眼前已有的东西进行渐进式改进，而不是从头重写一切。我、我明白从头重写对阿瑟·惠特尼（Arthur Whitney）来说是行得通的。而且我当然明白，有些时候那是正确做法，但这样做的代价太高了，特别是当你拥有一个生态系统和庞大的开发者基础时，
when it's something that's a community project and that, uh it you know rebuilding that community um or moving that community um especially when the size of c++ is just so much effort and so much work whereas just in like like investing in c++ and making it better, I think the returns are going to be much higher. But I have started to reach the point where the timescales on which, like we do good work on involving C++. I still believe that. I still believe that the committee does good work.
当这是一个社区项目，而且、呃，你知道，重建那个社区、或者迁移那个社区、特别是考虑到 C++ 的规模时，需要付出如此巨大的精力和工作；而相比之下，仅仅是投资 C++ 并让它变得更好，我认为回报会高得多。但我开始觉得，我们在演进 C++ 方面做好工作的时间尺度——我仍然相信这一点。我仍然相信委员会做出了出色的工作。
The timescales on which it happens trouble me. And it's not any one individual person's fault. It's not that people are dragging their feet. It's just the architecture of the system. I think the way
但它发生的时间尺度让我感到困扰。这并不是某个具体个人的过错。并不是人们在拖后腿。这只是系统的架构问题。我认为解决这个问题的办法
to deal with this is to get vendors that are active. And like I said before about these idea of extension sets, like a pound pragma feature tuple, right? So I have that, and that has one break, which is comma-separated expressions in parentheses now are tuples as opposed to invoking the comma operator, right? So that's a break, but you have to opt into it by using this. So I could develop this thing out and that could become a proposal. And then it's just something you vote up or down on.
是让活跃的厂商参与进来。就像我之前说的关于扩展集的想法，比如 `#pragma feature tuple`，对吧？所以我有这个，它有一个破坏性变更，即现在圆括号中的逗号分隔表达式是元组，而不是调用逗号运算符，对吧？所以这是一个破坏性变更，但你必须通过使用它来主动加入。所以我可以把这个东西开发出来，它可以成为一个提案。然后它就成了大家投票表决赞成还是反对的事情。
And then if it's approved, that becomes part of the next version, right? There's ways we can put out very coarse grained proposals. Because right now there's too many proposals, a lot of them for tiny, and you just clog the system up. And if we had something that was big and it was like a vendor supports it and it had users, it's just easier to say, yeah, we should take this thing because it's thought out and it's deployed and we can bang on it. Well, one of the fundamental problems of the C++ committee
如果它被批准了，那就成为下一个版本的一部分，对吧？我们可以通过一些方式提出非常粗粒度的提案。因为现在提案太多了，很多都针对微小的事情，结果把系统给堵塞了。如果我们有一个庞大的东西，有厂商支持它，并且有用户使用它，那就更容易说：“是的，我们应该采纳这个东西，因为它经过了深思熟虑并且已经部署了，我们可以对其进行打磨。”嗯，C++ 委员会的根本问题之一
is that it's not 350 people working on a single project. It's 350 people, each with their own independent vision and goals, each working on their own independent proposals, usually without a ton of consideration for what others are doing. There's a lack of goal setting at a high level on the committee. There's a lack of priorities. at a high level on the committee. There's a lack of priorities. And it's not a team. It's like even if we do set our goals and agree that we're going to do X, Y, or Z, or say that we agree that we're going to do X, Y, and Z, not everybody gets behind that. And without that team commitment, yeah, it's impossible for us to work together as a committee. We need to have a clear vision and direction, and it needs to be something that everybody buys into.
在于，它不是 350 个人在共同开发一个项目。而是 350 个人，每个人都有自己独立的愿景和目标，每个人都在开发自己独立的提案，通常根本不会过多考虑其他人正在做什么。委员会在宏观层面上缺乏目标设定。缺乏优先级。委员会在宏观层面上缺乏优先级。缺乏优先级。而且它不是一个团队。就好像即使我们设定了目标并同意我们要么做 X、Y 或 Z，或者说我们同意我们要么做 X、Y 和 Z，也不是每个人都会支持它。没有这种团队承诺，是的，我们作为委员会根本无法合作。我们需要一个清晰的愿景和方向，而且这必须是每个人都认可的东西。
And to your point about active vendors, I'll say this. This will sound controversial, but I fundamentally believe I'm right about this. I think it would be a much better model where the, just the vendors got together and decided upon new features. Um, all of the vendors of compilers, you know, who their customers are, their users. Um, and this, this current setup where we have tons and tons of users and other stakeholders involved, it so dilutes the vendors' voices. And honestly, like it makes a lot of the vendors very, very, very conservative
关于你提到的活跃厂商这一点，我要说的是。这听起来会很有争议，但我打心底里坚信我是对的。我认为如果只是让厂商聚在一起决定新功能，这将是一个好得多的模型。所有的编译器厂商，你知道，他们清楚自己的客户是谁，用户是谁。而且，这种我们有大量用户和其他利益相关者参与的现状，极大地淡化了厂商的声音。老实说，这使得许多厂商变得非常、非常、非常保守
in what they try to do in the committee. And oftentimes it forces the vendors' hands. I think that the people who implement c++ compilers um probably have a better perspective on what users as a whole need than taking a random handful of c++ users and saying hey why don't you tell the come dictate to the compiler vendors what they should do i'm'm certainly saying, like, certainly user input is important, but, like, I just think we've gotten to this place where there are some on the committee and in the community who think that people who develop C++ compilers
在他们在委员会中试图做的事情上。而且这往往迫使厂商做出妥协。我认为那些实现 C++ 编译器的人，可能比随机抓取一把 C++ 用户然后说“嘿，为什么不由你们来告诉、支配编译器厂商该做什么”更能看清整体用户真正需要什么。我当然是说，用户的输入固然重要，但是，我觉得我们已经到了这样一种地步：委员会和社区里的一些人认为，开发 C++ 编译器的人
somehow don't talk to users, or, like, users are their enemies. Like, that's absolutely not the case. If you're developing a C++ compiler, like, your goal is to that's absolutely not the case if you're developing a c++ compiler like your goal was to like serve the needs of your users so yeah i i in my ideal world you know if you look at how some of the web standards um run and some other you know more modern standards i would i would take you, representatives from all the major vendors and I would get them together to collaborate on new features. And I would maybe have a few people who are not from, you know, who are not compiler implementers. But it would have to be people whose full time job is evolving the language.
不知何故不与用户交流，或者好像用户是他们的敌人。绝对不是这样的。如果你在开发一个 C++ 编译器，你的目标就是——绝对不是这样的，如果你在开发一个 C++ 编译器，你的目标就是服务于用户的需求。所以，是的，在我的理想世界里，如果你看看某些网络标准是如何运行的，以及其他一些更现代的标准，我会挑选所有主要厂商的代表，让他们聚在一起合作开发新功能。我可能会邀请几个并非来自、你知道的、并非编译器实现者的人。但那必须是那些全职工作就是演进这门语言的人。
Yeah, I'd rather have a cartel model. Yeah, yeah, yeah i mean doesn't um uh python has something called i think the python language summit i maybe got the name of that wrong but basically there are you know everyone can submit peps or whatever they're called but they they also have a once a year language summit where only the developers that work on the Python language are there. And like, I think there's a couple people that might get special invites, but it's not, it's not like a open thing. Like there's PyCon, everyone can go to that. But then the language summit is just for the language implementers. Yep. I would like that model. Here's a question, Sean. So you mentioned that one of the things that is necessary for, you know, to just summarize, you know, carbon is a vision.
是的，我更想要一个卡特尔模型。对，对，对，我的意思是，Python 不是有什么叫做 Python 语言峰会之类的东西吗，我可能名字记错了，但基本上，大家都可以提交 PEP 或其他什么东西，但他们每年也会举办一次语言峰会，只有开发 Python 语言的开发者才能参加。而且，我觉得可能会有几个人获得特别邀请，但这并不是一个开放的活动。就像 PyCon 一样，每个人都可以去。但语言峰会只针对语言实现者。没错。我喜欢这种模型。这里有个问题，肖恩。你提到，为了概括——你知道，Carbon 是一个愿景，
CPP front is a vision, all these different visions. And in your opinion, any vision is possible and it's possible within the C++ that we currently have and we can get to it if we want to. And you said active vendors is something that would be necessary or would help with that. Are there other things like it kind of, you know, I think we had an episode a few episodes ago that was titled like C++ should leave ISO. Like, do you think these visions are possible within an ISO framework or does there have to be like a drastic governance model change in order to get there i mean i we know bryce's opinion now which is actually i'm not sure what your opinion is on
CPP Front 是一个愿景，所有这些不同的愿景。在你看来，任何愿景都是可能的，而且在我们现有的 C++ 范围内也是可能的，如果我们想的话就能实现它。你还说活跃厂商是必要的，或者会对这有所帮助。还有其他类似的事情吗——我想我们几期前有一集播客的标题叫作“C++ 应该离开 ISO”。你认为这些愿景在 ISO 框架内是可能的，还是必须进行激烈的治理模型变革才能实现？我的意思是，我们现在知道了布莱斯（Bryce）的观点，虽然其实我不确定你对
that but i well my opinion is is pretty simple um it is likely infeasible for c++ like to just, for like the C++ standard IP to just like get up and leave ISO. Like that's... I think that's another... It's a little bit more interesting. ISO has no motivation to do that.
这个问题的看法是什么。不过我的观点很简单——对于 C++ 来说，让 C++ 标准 IP 直接退出 ISO 几乎是不可行的。这就是……我认为这是另一个问题。这稍微更有意思一点。ISO 没有这样做的动力。
It'd be very complicated to do that. But there are other ways to develop standards that get published as iso standards um i'm not saying that c++ can't continue to be published as an iso standard i'm just saying it should not be developed uh uh at like on by an is ISO working group. I think it would be much better for C++ to form its own standards development organization to develop future revisions of C++
要做到这一点会非常复杂。但还有其他开发标准的方式，可以作为 ISO 标准发布。我并不是说 C++ 不能继续作为 ISO 标准发布，我只是说它不应该在一个 ISO 工作组中被开发。我认为对于 C++ 来说，成立自己的标准开发组织来开发 C++ 的未来版本，
and to publish those future revisions of C++ through ISO's fast-track processes that would allow it to be an open standard. And it would also allow C++ to pick an evolution model and a stakeholder model that makes sense for C++. That, to me, seems like the only practical way to dig ourselves out of this hole. Now, if we were starting from scratch, if we could just leave ISO completely, sure, I would say that that makes sense because in this day and age, ISO is not the right fit for C++. So that's pretty, that's kind of nuanced. I'm still not quite exactly sure where you stand,
并通过 ISO 的快速通道流程发布这些 C++ 的未来版本，会好得多；这能让它保持为一个开放标准。这也将使 C++ 能够选择对 C++ 来说合理的演进模型和利益相关者模型。在我看来，这是我们把自己从这个泥潭中挖出来的唯一切实可行的方法。现在，如果我们是从头开始，如果我们能完全离开 ISO，当然，我会说这合情合理，因为在这个时代，ISO 已经不再适合 C++ 了。所以这相当微妙、相当有细微差别。我仍然不太确定你的立场究竟是什么，
but my case is I don't really care that much, I guess. I mean, I'm just like trying to find my way through and try to arrive at a set of language features that is expressive and kind of continues to support existing code and provides a path for more productive development. And I don't know if the ISO really matters that much to me. You know, you're going to come out with standards every three years. I'm going to do my best to implement it and keep up with the other compilers.
但我的情况是，我其实没那么在意，我想。我的意思是，我只是在摸索前行，试图找到一组具有表现力的语言特性，这些特性既能继续支持现有代码，又能为更高效的开发提供一条路径。我不知道 ISO 对我来说是不是真的那么重要。你知道，你们每三年就会推出标准。我会尽我最大努力去实现它并跟上其他编译器的步伐。
But, you know, from my own standpoint, like, if there was a company that got sufficiently scared about successor languages that would be incompatible with their own source bases. Like, Herb seems kind of agitated, at least. You know, if they want to support this, I mean, they could handle the standardization approach however they want, whatever's good for their business. Just like Google is doing. I mean, Google has got a different development model
但是，从我自己的角度来看，如果有哪家公司对与自身代码库不兼容的继承者语言感到足够的恐惧——比如赫布（Herb）看起来至少有点焦虑。你知道，如果他们想支持这一点，他们可以随心所欲地处理标准化方法，只要对他们的业务有利就行。就像谷歌正在做的那样。我的意思是，谷歌有不同的开发模型
that works for them, or they hope will work for them. Yeah, it's interesting the way that you phrase that, because it helped me understand a bit about how you're operating. Just what you said, that you don't really care that much about what ISO is doing. And that sort of gets to the debate that we had earlier, that your point is sort of that, I think something like me or maybe most C++ users or some set of C++ users, this is a high value on things being standardized.
这对他们很管用，或者他们希望对他们管用。是的，你表达的方式很有趣，因为这有助于我理解你是如何运作的。就像你刚刚说的，你其实并不那么在意 ISO 在做什么。这有点类似于我们之前进行的辩论，你的观点是，像我这样的某个人，或者也许大多数 C++ 用户，或者某一部分 C++ 用户，非常重视事物被标准化。
Not most users, a tiny percent. Yeah, maybe it's a tiny percent. Maybe it's a tiny percent that values things being standardized. And your point is like, look, I'm just going to build the best features that I can in my compiler and other other compilers can build them if they want like i want to focus on the language not necessarily what's standard i i wasn't up to date at all with standardization prior to starting circle like i had all these ideas i didn't know that 17 was a release year i didn't know that 14 was a release year i don't't even know that 14 was a release year, I don't think. I was on 11, and then, you know, you just do your work.
不是大多数用户，只是一小部分。是的，也许只是一小部分。也许只有一小部分人重视事物被标准化。你的观点是，看，我只想在我的编译器中构建我能构建的最佳功能，如果其他编译器愿意，它们也可以构建这些功能——我想专注于语言本身，而不一定是标准是什么。在开始编写 Circle 之前，我对标准化完全一无所知——我有所有这些想法，我不知道 17 是发布年，我甚至不知道 14 是发布年，我不认为我知道。我当时还在用 11，然后，你知道，你就只管做你的工作。
I would rarely go to the standard to look stuff up because I wasn't, like, writing that kind of code. I'd go to CPP Reference and get, you know, clarification on that. And I certainly wasn't reading the monthly mailings. And I don't think a... But they weren't monthly until seven well okay whatever that's that's my point that's my point you know like that is nobody cares about that i know and um yeah i mean i don't i don't have any hard feelings
我很少去看标准来查阅资料，因为我不是在写那种代码。我会去 CPP Reference 查阅资料获得澄清。我当然也没有读过每月的邮件列表。而且我不认为……但它们在 7 之前不是每月的——好吧，不管怎样，这就是我的观点，这就是我的观点，你知道，就像没有人关心那个一样，我知道，而且……是的，我的意思是，我对
about the committee really like keep doing what you're doing. That's fine. If, if I, if, if vendors like myself or bigger ones would, you know, periodically present you a, like a mega proposal where it's a simple up or down vote. This is how you can get interface generics, like C++, OX concepts. And we thought,
委员会真的没有什么不好的感觉，继续做你们正在做的事吧。没关系。如果像我这样的厂商或更大的厂商定期向你们提交一个庞大的提案，这是一个简单的赞成或反对投票。这就是你如何获得接口泛型（如 C++ OX 概念）的方法，我们对此进行了思考，
we thought it through, we've deployed it. You can just take this thing as is because that would make it easier to merge into the standard. Hopefully if they want to provide that, that's like a good service. And then for customers that really just want to remain with ISO C++, they would benefit from that because they would get accelerated features as well. I just want to write a better compiler, a better language.
我们已经对其进行了思考并部署了它。你可以直接采用这个东西，因为这会更容易合并到标准中。希望如果他们想提供这一点，那将是一项很好的服务。而且对于那些真的只想留在 ISO C++ 中的客户，他们也会从中受益，因为他们也将获得加速推出的功能。我只想编写一个更好的编译器，一门更好的语言。
And I think the committee has to figure out how to stay relevant. See, I think most on the committee, your perspective is I can do valuable work on developing new C++ features without having to propose them for standardization. Like for a lot of people on the committee, whether or not their work is valuable depends entirely upon whether it gets into the standard. They should be writing software. Right. debacle if instead of the losing side walking away from the committee it's perhaps unfair
而且我认为委员会必须弄清楚如何保持其相关性。你看，我认为委员会中的大多数人，你们的观点是：我可以在开发新的 C++ 特性方面做出有价值的工作，而不必将它们提议进行标准化。对于委员会中的许多人来说，他们的工作是否有价值完全取决于它是否进入了标准。他们应该去写软件。Right. 混乱之处在于，如果不是失败的一方离开委员会，而是——也许这并不公平——
what if both sides had just like developed their version of concepts in their compilers and just not really worried that much about what the committee their version of concepts in their compilers and just not really worried that much about what the committee was doing. Like, okay, the committee didn't standardize my version of concepts. I'll just keep developing it.
如果双方只是各自在编译器中开发了他们版本的概念，而不太担心委员会在做什么呢？好吧，委员会没有标准化我版本的概念。我只会继续开发它。
I think we might be in a better world today. Yeah, I think there would have likely been a compromise at some point where they said, okay, let's... And to be fair, that did happen for some period of time. But I think eventually what happened was the folks that were working on the OX concepts and on the implementation of it,
我想我们今天可能会处于一个更好的世界。是的，我想在某个时刻很可能会达成妥协，当时他们会说，好吧，让我们……公平地说，在一段时间内确实发生了这种情况。但我认为最终发生的事情是，那些致力于 OX 概念及其实现的人们，
which was more mature than the concepts light, they became disheartened. And for them, it didn't seem like it was a valuable investment of their time at some point because the committee seemed to be moving in the direction of this other proposal. And I think that is the downside, I guess, that if the committee does decide to do something, it's just drastically different than what you're doing. Yeah. But I do understand now, I think, a little bit better what you were uh the point
其成熟度高于 Concepts Lite，他们变得灰心丧气。对他们来说，在某个时刻，这似乎并不是对其时间有价值的投资，因为委员会似乎正在朝着另一个提案的方向发展。我认为这确实是负面影响，我想，如果委员会决定做某事，而这与你正在做的事情有天壤之别的话。是的。但现在我确实更好地理解了你当时表达的观点，
you were making you don't you don't need anyone's permission to write software just because something's right it hasn't been put into an international standard document you know you don't need to wait for that to write software and people aren't waiting yeah like the game industry has developed their own set of tools for reflection and things and they're like really kludgy yep but you know they need it and so they go and things. And they're like really kludgy. Yep. But you know, they need it. And so they go forward and do it. They're not just waiting for the day.
你写软件不需要任何人的批准，仅仅因为某个东西是正确的、还没有被放进国际标准文档里，你知道，你不需要等待那个来写软件，而且人们也没有在等待。是的，就像游戏行业已经开发了他们自己的反射工具集之类的东西，而且它们真的很笨拙。没错。但你知道，他们需要它，所以他们勇往直前地去做。他们不只是在等待那一天的到来。
And I mean, I like, even as one of the senior committee leadership, I constantly question whether the work that we are doing is valuable. And I think anybody who is deeply involved in C++ standardization, you know, you stick your head up from being down in the weeds and you have to ask yourself, was this really, was this the best use of my time? Was this like, was spending, you know, six months trying to hammer out like the details of this one specific thing
我的意思是，即使作为委员会的高级领导层之一，我也经常质疑我们正在做的工作是否有价值。我想任何深度参与 C++ 标准化的人，当你从琐事中抬起头来时，你都不得不问自己，这真的是——这是对我时间的最好利用吗？这就像是，花费六个月的时间试图敲定这一个特定事物的细节，
in this feature. Was that truly, truly like a valuable contribution? Um, yeah. And, and I mean, I think it's, I think it's good for us to, to question that. I certainly hope that lots of other people in the committee ask themselves that question. I certainly do. Yeah, I'm not even going there. This is all you. Yeah. So here's a, I mean, this is kind of a specific question, but I kind of assumed in my head when you were talking about the C++ OX concepts that you were in the process of adding that that was going to be not possible to coexist with C++20 concepts.
在这个特性中。这真的、真的是一个有价值的贡献吗？嗯，是的，而且我的意思是，我认为我们质疑这一点是好的。我当然希望委员会中的许多其他人也会问自己这个问题。我当然会。是的，我甚至不去想那个。这全都是你的功劳。是的。所以这里有一个——我的意思是，这是一个相当具体的问题，但我脑子里有一种假设：当你谈论 C++ OX 概念时，你正处于添加它的过程中，那将无法与 C++20 概念共存。
But it sounds like you're still fully supporting both. Yeah, so C++20 concepts are not concepts. What does C++20 give you? It gives you a concept definition or declaration, which is like a variable template. It's got a bool value. You give it some number of template parameters or arguments and it's true or false. It gives you a requires clause which
但听起来你仍然在全力支持这两者。是的，所以 C++20 概念并不是概念。C++20 给你带来了什么？它给你提供了一个概念定义或声明，类似于变量模板。它有一个布尔值。你给它一定数量的模板参数或实参，它就是真或假。它给你提供了一个 requires 子句，
you can put on the end of a template or a member and it evaluates that and if it's false then it removes it from the overload candidate set. It also gives you like it requires expression which is the same thing but inside an expression. These are like mechanisms that use the same keywords as C++, LX concepts,
你可以把它放在模板或成员的末尾，它会对其进行求值，如果为假，则将其从重载候选项集合中移除。它还给你提供了一个 requires 表达式，这是一样的东西，只不过是在表达式内部。这些机制使用了与 C++ OX 概念相同的关键字，
but they, they just work as like normal language features. They don't lock you into this alternative system of early type checking. And, and the C++, OX concepts that I'm implementing or that Carbon is going to implement and they call those interfaces and impuls and Rust calls traits and impuls and Swift calls protocols, those are basically orthogonal to what we got in 20. The early type checking does not exist in 20. It's a lot harder.
但它们只是作为普通的语言特性来运作的。它们不会把你锁死在早期类型检查的这种替代系统中。而且，我正在实现的 C++ OX 概念，或者 Carbon 将要实现的、他们称之为接口（interface）和实现（impl）、而 Rust 称之为 trait 和 impl、Swift 称之为 protocol 的这些东西，它们基本上与我们在 20 中获得的东西正交。早期类型检查在 20 中并不存在。这要困难得多。
It requires, I think, creating new kinds of data types like generic classes. Yeah, they all coexist, and I think it's clear, at least in my implementation, it's clear the distinction between the C++20 concept and the interface that I'm having. There's a different set of keywords. They go in different places in the template declarations. I'm definitely committed to providing both of those. And also, it's sort of incremental.
我认为这需要创建新型的数据类型，比如泛型类。是的，它们共存了，而且我认为很清楚，至少在我的实现中，C++20 概念和我有接口之间的区别是很清晰的。有一组不同的关键字。它们在模板声明中处于不同的位置。我绝对致力于提供这两者。而且，这也是某种程度上渐进式的。
You don't actually have to fully opt into these interfaces because the interfaces I've written, it's like a... So the interface in Carbon or in the trait in Rust, it looks like a class specifier. So you have an interface name, and then it's got some list of associated types,
你实际上不必完全加入这些接口，因为我编写的接口就像是一个……所以 Carbon 中的接口或 Rust 中的 trait，它看起来像一个类说明符。所以你有一个接口名称，然后它有一些关联类型的列表，
which look like typedefs, or function declarations for the associated functions. And that defines your interface. And in my implementation, that interface is also a concept. So you can pass that around as a concept. So you can pass that around as a concept parameter. You can use that in a requires clause. You can use that to constrain a placeholder parameter. You can use it wherever you use a concept. And it's just like a better C++20 concept. It does type checking over the whole type as opposed to just evaluating this Boolean expression. So in that sense, it gives you like a half measure way in.
看起来像类型别名，或者是关联函数的函数声明。这就定义了你的接口。在我的实现中，那个接口同时也是一个概念。所以你可以把那个当作一个概念传递。因此你可以将其作为概念参数传递。你可以在 requires 子句中使用它。你可以用它来约束占位符参数。你可以在任何使用概念的地方使用它。它就像是一个更好的 C++20 概念。它对整个类型进行类型检查，而不是仅仅对这个布尔表达式进行求值。所以在某种意义上，它为你提供了一条半信半疑的切入途径。
And then if you want to go all the way in, you can make a generic function with the generic keyword, and that'll do the early type checking. And that's going to require like some real thought on the part of the users, because you have to be able to marshal all of the capabilities of the types and put those in the declaration.
然后，如果你想彻底采用，你可以用 generic 关键字制作一个泛型函数，那将进行早期的类型检查。这将需要用户进行一些真正的思考，因为你必须能够调动类型的所有功能并将其放入声明中。
It's pretty challenging for me because I've never really dealt with this kind of generics before, but other languages are using it apparently with success and people are not complaining so much about the error messages in these other languages. So hopefully we can get errors to be more clear and the documentation would be
对我来说相当具有挑战性，因为我以前从未真正处理过这种泛型，但其他语言显然在成功地使用它，而且人们对这些其他语言中的错误信息的抱怨也没有那么多。所以希望我们能让错误信息更清晰，并且文档也将
kind of like enforced almost as part of the definition of the function. Yeah. Yeah. Interesting. So this really is just like you're saying, you know, you said this earlier, it's just stop being scared. We can have it all.
几乎作为函数定义的一部分被强制执行。是的。是的。有趣。所以这实际上就像你说的，你知道，你之前说过的，就是别再害怕了。我们可以拥有一切。
Everything can live in C++. Because I was thinking we can't have two different types of concepts. Concepts are concepts. Which also should be the title of this appointment. Well, I mean, I'm using new keywords to prevent confusion, right? Yeah. Just like Carmen is using different keywords. But I liked how you said that.
一切都可以存在于 C++ 中。因为我曾认为我们不能有两种不同类型的概念。概念就是概念。这也应该是这次任命的标题。好吧，我的意思是，我正在使用新的关键字来防止混淆，对吧？是的。就像 Carbon 使用不同的关键字一样。但我喜欢你刚才的说法。
The concepts that we have in C++20 aren't really concepts. Well, they're not. I mean, they're not the generics. That's why people are still agitated. They're still angry about it. But I think we can add everything. I think that was one of the objections to my CPP Now talk from people was that I've added a bunch of new mechanisms. You're making the language too big.
我们在 C++20 中拥有的概念并不是真正的概念。嗯，它们不是。我的意思是，它们不是泛型。这就是为什么人们仍然感到焦虑。他们对此仍然很生气。但我认为我们可以添加一切。我认为那是人们对我 CPP Now 演讲的反对意见之一，即我添加了一堆新机制。你把语言搞得太大了。
They say you're making the language too big. And what I said was that this is reducing the time to solution. It drives me crazy when people bring up this complexity argument because i i think it's something that people bring up when they like don't like something but they don't have any technical reason for why they don't like it right think about a um a jet cockpit like 50 years ago it was all pressure gauges hundreds of pressure gauges and that was that was a simple design and now you have like a couple of like LCD touch panels. And, and that's hundreds of times more complicated.
他们说你把语言搞得太大了。而我所说的是，这减少了得出解决方案的时间。每当人们提出这个复杂度论点时，我都快疯了，因为我认为这是人们在不喜欢某事但又说不出不喜欢它的任何技术原因时才会提出来的话，对吧？想想 50 年前的喷气式飞机驾驶舱，它全都是压力表，数以百计的压力表，那是一个简单的设计，而现在你有了几个像 LCD 触控面板的东西。
Right. But it gives you the information you want right there. The, the time to solution is very quick. You can display whatever you want. It's got a whole, a whole lot more capability yet in every way. It's,
然后，这复杂了数百倍。对吧？但它能直接为你提供你想要的信息。解决问题的时间非常快。你可以显示你想显示的任何东西。它拥有多得多的功能，然而在各个方面，
it's better. I mean, it's definitely more complex. Digital systems are just more complex than analog ones. But they're better at the same time. And nobody's expecting you to learn all of those things. Nobody expects you to know how every feature in
它都更优秀。我的意思是，它绝对更复杂。数字系统就是比模拟系统更复杂。但它们同时又更优秀。而且没有人期望你学会所有这些东西。没有人期望你知道
any modern device works anymore. But if you need to find it, you can find it. And for most of your tasks, it's just much easier to use. Well, and there's always this specter of teachability. You know, oh, well, if we have all these things that we have to teach the old thing and the new thing. You know, I and people often joke about that.
任何现代设备中的每个功能是如何工作的。但如果你需要找到它，你可以找到它。对于你的大多数任务来说，它使用起来要容易得多。嗯，而且总是存在关于可教性的幽灵。你知道，哦，好吧，如果我们有所有这些必须教授的东西——旧东西和新东西。你知道，我，人们经常对此开玩笑。
Everybody who's, you know, all the big C++ figures who talk about making the language simpler, that they're really trying to make it simpler through more complexity. And people act like that's a, that's like a ha-ha thing. But I think that in a lot of cases, you do make the presentation of something simpler by making it more complex.
所有那些谈论让语言变得更简单的 C++ 大牛们，他们实际上是在试图通过引入更多的复杂性来让它变得更简单。人们表现得好像这是一个“哈哈”的笑话。但我认为，在很多情况下，你确实通过让某事变得更复杂，从而使它的呈现方式变得更简单。
And like, you do get to a simpler language by adding more features. And I think we've talked about this in the past, that at any point in time, if you ask the C++ community how the evolution of C++ is going, 50% of people are going to tell you it's moving too fast, and 50% are going to tell you it's not moving fast enough. Yeah, it's this fear of adding new
而且，你确实可以通过添加更多功能来获得一门更简单的语言。我想我们过去也讨论过这一点，在任何时间点，如果你问 C++ 社区 C++ 的演进进展如何，50% 的人会告诉你它发展得太快了，而另外 50% 的人会告诉你它发展得不够快。是的，就是这种对添加新事物的恐惧，
things or the fear of adding new things solely for the fear of adding them. Right. I think that's the one objection I don't have any sympathy for. Yeah. I think that's the one objection I don't have any sympathy for. I think there's a lot of other things. Okay, I understand your opinion.
或者仅仅因为害怕而添加新事物的恐惧。对吧。我认为这是我唯一不同情的反对意见。是的。我认为这是我唯一不同情的反对意见。我觉得还有很多其他事情。好吧，我理解你的观点。
But on this one, I just do not. To be fair, the one place where I hesitate on this is on questions of what goes into the standard library. On questions of scope like I'm not saying like we should add everything. Like it has to still be
但关于这一点，我实在无法苟同。平心而论，我对此犹豫不决的一个地方在于关于标准库中应该包含什么的问题。关于范围的问题，比如我并不是说我们应该添加一切。它必须仍然
like a valuable thing. I'm just saying that like there's no reason that we shouldn't add, you know, interfaces when we already have concepts because clearly that's a thing that's valuable and that would you know, benefit a great deal
就像一件有价值的东西。我只是说，没有理由不添加，你知道的，接口，当我们已经有了概念，因为很明显这是一件有价值的事情，并且你知道的，会让广大用户受益匪浅。
of users. Well, not even saying add. I'm just saying there needs to be an active project to discover how they would actually behave in the C++ environment. Yeah. But I don't want to suggest that I'm saying that we should add everything that anybody might want to add to C++, in particular the Stated Library. Please don't send more proposals. Yeah, we're just
好吧，甚至不是说添加。我只是说需要有一个积极的项目来探索它们在C++环境中到底会如何表现。是的。但我不想暗示我是说我们应该把任何人可能想加到C++里的东西都加进去，特别是标准库。请不要再发提案了。是的，我们只是
saying that the weight of the compiler, like the number of lines of the compiler, the number of countable discrete features isn't a good guidance of the user experience, how complex the language is. Because you add first-class language features and the user experience improves.
说编译器的分量，比如编译器的代码行数、可数离散特征的数量，并不是衡量用户体验或语言复杂度的良好指南。因为你添加了一流的语言特性，用户体验反而得到了改善。
Absolutely. Absolutely. I think that JetCockpit example is a really good one. That's a really nice way of putting it. If you think about it over the past 20 to 30 years, computers have become far more accessible. It's like everybody's grandparents and kids is able to use a computer because they all have these much simpler interfaces and much more user-friendly operating systems. And yet vastly more complex than everything. Yeah, exactly. It's like wildly more complex.
绝对是的。绝对是的。我认为那个JetCockpit的例子真的很好。这是一种非常精妙的表达方式。如果你仔细想想，在过去20到30年里，计算机变得容易接近得多。就像每个人的祖父母和小孩都能使用计算机，因为他们都有这些简单得多的界面和更加用户友好的操作系统。然而其复杂程度却呈指数级增长。是的，没错。简直是极其复杂。
And I think we can square those things. We can do that at the language design level too. I'm putting in choice types. I'm putting these things in. And it's like it's not harder for the user. It's only harder for me. Yes. All right.
而且我认为我们可以将这两者协调起来。我们在语言设计层面也可以做到这一点。我正在引入选择类型。我正在引入这些东西。这其实对用户来说并不难。它只对我难。是的。好的。
So I think we got to talk about the last thing that we promised the users we would talk about. Connor, have you read Moby Dick? Oh, yeah. Tune in next week for part three, the final part of this three-part conversation with Sean Baxter. Thanks for listening.
所以我觉得我们得聊聊最后那个我们答应听众要聊的话题。康纳，你读过《白鲸》吗？哦，读过。请收听下周的第三部分，也就是与肖恩·巴克斯特的这三部分对话的最后一部分。感谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你们喜欢，祝有个美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。